Я думаю, що порушити достатньо
строгі умови домашнього карантину,
який ми зберігаємо усією родиною
вже чотири тижні
мене змусила саме ця цікавість.
Так, по-перше, цікавість,
а по-друге, мені хотілося
долучитися до національної справи,
бо це дійсно дуже об'єднує.
Дорогі десятикласники! Вітаю вас
на уроці української літератури.
Мене звати Анастасія Євдокимова.
Я керую промоцією читання
в Українському інституті книги.
Тож сьогодні ми поговоримо про те,
як читати книжки.
І тема нашого уроку – драма Лесі Українки
«Лісова пісня»,
її фольклорно-міфологічна основа.
Сьогодні наша учениця,
наша десятикласниця – Марія.
Добрий день, Маріє!
Вітаю вас!
Ви готові до уроку
української літератури?
Я дуже хотіла потрапити на нього,
але не можу сказати,
що я морально готова.
Мені треба звикнути з тим, що за партою
так відповідально сидіти, пані Анастасіє.
Нічого, зараз вам буде дуже просто.
Мені дуже цікаво!
Вам буде дуже просто і приємно.
Отже, ми з вами починали говорити
про творчість Лесі Українки
на попередніх уроках.
Ми говорили про «Contra spem spero»
(«Без надії сподіваюсь»).
Ми говорили про її громадянську лірику,
ми говорили про пейзажну та інтимну
лірику, про драми в її житті.
Сьогодні ми поговоримо про драматургію.
На одному з попередніх занять
у вас було завдання
намалювати лінії життя
й творчості Лесі Українки
та нанести всі важливі дати
з поетичних збірок, драм, перепитій.
От зараз настав час,
аби нанести ще один текст,
один з вершинних текстів
не лише Лесі Українки,
а й загалом світової літератури –
драму «Лісова пісня».
Отже, пригадаймо що таке драма.
У нас є три роди літератури:
епос, лірика і драма.
Чим вони відрізняються між собою?
Це до мене питання?
Я багато про драму просто знаю.
Пригадаємо, що епос – це текст,
написаний в ширину.
Ми читаємо з вами новелу, роман.
Текст написаний в ширину – це все епос.
Все, що лірика – це те,
що фактично в стовпчик.
Вся поезія – це лірика.
Тоді драма – це текст,
розписаний в ролях.
У нас є: наприклад, Марія сказала,
пані Анастасія сказала.
А ще є коментарі автора.
Але ми ще до цього повернемось.
Отже, епос, лірика й драма –
три роди літератури.
Ми з вами говорили про лірику
Лесі Українки, тобто про її поезію.
Ми не говоритимемо про її прозові твори,
але говоритимемо про драматичні.
Отже, що таке драматична поема?
А «Лісова пісня» – саме драматична поема.
Маріє, прочитаєте нам, будь ласка?
Так. Пані Анастасіє, я вас
повинна попередити,
що в мене українська мова не дуже добра.
Я взагалі в школі її майже не вивчала.
А вивчала лише
в університеті факультативно.
Зараз я продовжую займатися з вчителями.
Тож ви мене вибачте, якщо я робитиму
помилкИ. Чи помИлки?
Ми з вами разом виправлятимемо.
Добре. То правильно як – помИлки?
ПомилкИ!
О, я правильно сказала. Добре, почнемо.
Отже, це віршований твір, який поєднує -
з одного боку він є драмою,
бо він розписаний в ролях, з іншого –
він є ліро-епічною формою.
Тобто, великим за обсягом текстом,
але написаний віршем.
В основі драматичної поеми –
динамічний сюжет.
Тобто, події відбуваються одна за одною.
Є певні конфлікти.
Але зовнішніх подій не так багато.
Все зосереджено всередині самої драми,
всередині кожного діалогу,
всередині кожної репліки.
Ми з вами побачимо, як це відбувається
у Лесі Українки.
Давайте ознайомимося із тим,
що таке феєрія.
Це для нас буде важливо.
Це хотілося б підкреслити.
Адже і про природнє, і про людське
ми говоритимемо сьогодні
і на наступних уроках.
Це феєрія. А що ж таке драма-феєрія?
Феєрія – це вистава
з казково-драматичним сюжетом,
а драма-феєрія – драматичний твір
з казковим сюжетом.
Отже драма-феєрія – це визначення
жанру визначення
твору Лесі Українкки «Лісова пісня»,
про який ми сьогодні говоритимемо.
Там є щось міфічне, щось казкове.
І як вони поєднані – людське й природнє.
Всі ці елементи, які ми щойно
прочитали на дошці,
ми їх віднайдемо у творі Лесі Українки.
В листі до сестри Ольги від 27 листопада
1911 року написала такі рядки...
Я хочу звернути увагу на те,
що епістолярна спадщина,
тобто листи Лесі Українки,
займають окреме місце в її творчості.
Чому? Тому що вона дуже багато
писала листів і вони збереглися.
До сучасників, як до її дядька
Михайла Драгоманова,
листування з матір’ю, коханим,
з дорогою Ольгою Кобилянською, про що ми
неодмінно поговоримо наприкінці теми.
Це варте окремого розгляду,
як листувалися ці дві найбільші
авторки того періоду,
як вони одна до одної зверталися,
ділилися творчістю.
Адже листи – окрема історія.
У них не було телефонного зв'язку,
емейлів, вони могли лише листуватися,
обмінюватися цими ідеями.
А також ми розуміємо,
що 12-томник Лесі Українки,
який вийшов ще в Радянському Союзі,
де було кілька томів, привчених листам
і з листами, ввійшли не всі листи.
Була цензура, оскільки радянська влада
не дуже любила брата Лесі Українки
і вирізала всі факти.
Так і багато інших важливих фактів.
Але вже в часи незалежної
України кілька років тому
почали виходити ці відтворені листи
з широким літературознавчим коментарем
Віри Агеєвої,
дослідниці Лесі Українки.
Їх можна знайти й почитати, що ж там саме
і як насправді писала Леся Українка.
Ми з вами відкриваємо лист
до її сестри Ольги,
який вона написала восени 1911 року.
Нагадаю, що влітку 1911 року
вона написала п’єсу,
у жовтні вона її відредагувала.
І от вона пише до сестри Ольги.
Що ж вона пише, Маріє?
Так може сказати зараз кожна мама
на карантині. Вибачте.
Так. Писала 10-12 днів, але відчувала
таку тяжкість, так їй було складно,
хоча ніби то текст з’явився так легко
й швидко...
У підручниках ми, звісно, знайдемо
інформацію про те,
що там вже була просто міфологія:
Леся Українка її відтворила.
А насправді все було не так просто.
Їй було складно це писати.
У чому складність цього тексту?
Ми далі з’ясуємо.
Ще один лист до матері
від 2 січня 1912 року.
Леся Українка написала:
Де вона в цей час була?
Вона у цей час була на Кавказі в Кутаїсі
й от згадує рідну Волинь
і тужить за лісами.
Колодяжне – село на Волині,
де була хата Лесі Українки,
де їй батько поставив будинок.
Мріла – ввижалася, наче я її бачила.
Розповідали Лесі Українці
в дитинстві про мавку.
І зачарував її цей світ і не відпускав.
Тому що лише жінка могла
написати про жінку,
лише жінка могла зрозуміти Мавку,
її природу.
Максим Рильський написав так:
Серпанок – це туман.
Тобто, її творчість легка як туман
і дуже музична.
Насправді, в усіх виданнях
«Лісової пісні» ви знайдете вкінці ноти.
А хто ж їх написав? Хто грав?
Ми з’ясуємо пізніше.
Романтична основа твору – це те,
з чого твір виростає
і чим нас сьогодні приваблює.
Ми читали багато романтичних творів
у нашій шкільній програмі,
ми в 9 класі читали «Марусю»
Квітки-Основ’яненка,
де були Маруся й Василь,
вони кохали одне одного,
попрощалися на кладовищі.
Потім Маруся померла.
Сумна історія кохання.
Але ми це пригадуємо.
Десь я вже чула таке у Шекспіра.
Була історія Шекспірівська
про Марічку та Івана –
«Тіні забутих предків»
Михайла Коцюбинського.
Ми нещодавно її читали.
Теж романтична основа твору,
теж нещасливе кохання.
Щасливим чи ні буде кохання
Мавки й Лукаша,
головних героїв «Лісової пісні»
ми дізнаємося лише наприкінці.
Тому у нас є така інтрига, і чому
нам потрібно цей текст дочитати.
Текст 1911 року.
Нам це важливо тому, що Лесі Українці
на той момент було 40 років.
Це була зріла авторка, яка вже
була відомою й популярною,
яка входила в канон тогочасної літератури
й була серед ключових авторок.
1911 рік – унікальний рік,
коли живі були ще всі:
І. Франко, М. Коцюбинський,
Леся Українка,
коли вже починали писати автори,
які в 20-х роках стануть популярними.
Вже почали публікуватися П. Тичина,
перші спроби П. Вороного
і всі вони в один час творять.
І в цей момент синергії, співтворчості
з’являється цей вершинний текст.
Це дуже цікаво.
Що є ознакою класики?
Ознакою класики є те, що всі її частини
«Лісової пісні» по-різному є актуальними
й актуальними стають в різний час.
Можемо заново для себе прочитувати
й воно буде для нас близьким.
Так, нам потрібно пояснювати якісь окремі
слова, такі як серпанок, наприклад,
але для нас цей текст актуальний
і зрозумілий.
Отже, місце написання
твору - Кутаїсі, літо 1911 року.
Отже, написала вона «Лісову пісню»
не в Україні.
Місце дії - волинськи ліси, або Полісся.
Якщо ми не знаємо, що таке Полісся,
не пригадуємо,
то запрошую вас після уроку
подивитися, яким є Полісся,
відео «Україна з неба»
від експедиції «Ukraїner»,
які проїхали всю Україну
й побачили її з неба.
Вони покажуть різноманіття Полісся,
аби ви відчули той настрій,
який відчувала сама Леся Українка.
Дух Полісся.
Або ж зможемо пригадати, як ми
читали пейзажну лірику Лесі,
коли вона їхала з Волині до моря,
як вона бачила свою рідну Волинь.
Отже, композиція драми,
структура – це пролог і 3 дії.
Але ми з вами, Маріє, пам’ятаємо,
що драма починається не з прологу,
а раніше.
З чого починається драматичний текст?
Відкриємо книжечку. Підказка.
З назви! Звісно.
Ми перегортаємо ще сторінку, ще.
І от ми бачимо
Список діячів.
Список дійових осіб. У випадку
Лесі Українки – список діячів.
Тобто список тих,
хто бере участь у драмі,
хто говорите, хто з’явиться на сцені.
Це була моя улюблена сторінка
завжди на уроках літератури.
Ти собі якось уявляєш тих діячів,
а потім думаєш,
виправдалося твоє сподівання
чи твоя фантазія, чи ні.
Так-так. Пам’ятаю.
Список діячів тут написано.
Іноді автори подають описи,
особливі прикмети
Характери
Так, характеристику цих осіб. У всіх
авторів по-різному трапляється.
Отже, з’ясуємо, що таке ремарка,
бо нам з ними теж треба буде працювати -
коли автор відволікається
й розповідає нам,
що розташовано на сцені,
де і як.
Куди пішов герой і як
змінилася декорація.
Коли автор дає нам свій кометар
щодо тексту.
Цей коментар для кого є цінним, Маріє?
Для того, хто читає?
Так. А ще для кого?
Якщо драма – це текст, який теоретично
чи практично може втілитися на сцені.
Це може бути поставлено для режисерів
та сценаристів.
Це підказка для тих, хто потім
це втілюватиме.
Як це бачив автор.
Він не може давати ніяких
прямих настанов,
але може давати вказівки.
Я таке бачила більше у п’єсах.
А п’єса – це і є драматичний твір.
Драматичний твір, п’єса –
це все синоніми.
Вона є драмою для читання, але
вона є доброю драмою для постановки.
А про сучасні постановки
й інтерпретацію цього тексту
ми поговоримо наприкінці уроку,
коли все повторюватимемо.
Так виглядав автограф цієї п’єси.
Так Леся Українка працювала
над цим текстом.
Щось закреслювала, щось дописувала.
Але 10-12 днів напруженої праці –
це досить багато.
Таке непримітне перше видання 1914 року,
яке нас навіть не інтригує, на відміну
від різних яскравих сучасних видань,
як наприклад те, яке у вас у руках,
де класні ілюстрації,
які хочеться гортати
й відкривати для себе.
Отже, ми починаємо читати «Лісову пісню»,
починаємо ми з "Прологу". Маріє...
Я тут через слово розумію.
А я зараз вам пояснюватиму.
У нас є опція – пані Анастасія,
яка може все пояснити.
Тобто ми зупинятимемося на кожному слові?
Ні. На цілісних реченнях,
щоб їх зрозуміти.
Напросилася я на літературу,
тепер сама трохи попала.
Ну добре, поїхали. Пролог.
Ми для себе уявляємо, яким є
той простір, де відбувається дія.
Прастарий – дуже старий дуб.
Як ми собі уявляємо лісове озеро,
що є кущики, очерет, болотце
і так це болотце утворилося
з лісового струмка.
Озеро, тиховоди.
Уявіть собі озеро, а воно вкрите такими
дрібними крапочками – ряскою, лататтям…
Що таке латаття?
Латаття – маленькі листочки
з водяними ліліями.
Так, це гарно!
З чистим плесом, з чистою ділянкою
посередині. Воно дуже красиве й спокійне.
Так, як ми собі можемо
уявити будь-яке інше озеро.
Все дике, але водночас дуже таємниче,
не сумне, ніжне, дає гарний настрій.
Провесна – початок весни.
Щойно сходять сніги й починає
природа прокидатися.
Зараз провесна?
Вже глибша весна.
По узліссі і на галяві зеленіє перший
ряст і цвітуть проліски та сон-трава.
Вкриті бростю – бруньками. Бруньки
вже є, а листя ще немає.
– На цьому ми зупиняємось.
Отже, ми розуміємо,
що туман то розсіюється,
то знову стелиться.
Природа красива?
Красиво виглядає!
Ми розуміємо, що ми біля озера,
початок весни.
І ось яким життям живе це озеро.
Це лише вступ, пролог.
І зараз ми зрозуміємо,
що ж на цьому озері відбувається?
І взагалі який настрій нашої драми?
Що відбувається в природі, коли вона
в такому гармонійному стані
і їй начебто нічого не заважає?
Що відбувається? Читаємо далі, Маріє.
Той, що греблі рве –
один із тих персонажів,
які представляють природнє.
І будуть ті, які представляють людське.
Той, що греблі рве – той, який зриває
будь-яку перешкоду.
Вітрюган, неспокійний. Таким він постає.
Міниться барвами – переливається.
Наша людина!
...Туман розбігається, вона синішає.
Я хочу туди!
Ви хочете туди! Ми вже майже там.
Ми чуємо й для себе відчуваємо,
яким є цей настрій.
І от з’являється Той, що греблі рве.
І він каже нам.
Починаємо читати:
Він зриває всі перешкоди, які на воді,
все, що люди набудували.
Він зриває. Бо це йому заважає.
І виникає питання куди біжить
Той, що греблі рве?
І от він несеться й зустрічає потерчаток.
Потерчата – позашлюбні діти,
які померли нехрещеними.
І от вони перетворюються в духів,
живуть у воді,
перетворюються згодом у нявок.
І от вони сидять і оберігають
якесь своє середовище.
І от Той, що греблі рве розбурхав
їхнє середовище.
Тобто коли його питають,
що він шукає, він відповів:
Я шукаю русалку,
бо чарівнішої за неї немає.
Я готовий перевернути весь світ,
аби лише знайти її.
А вони кажуть: почекай, не треба,
не каламуть воду!
Твоя русалка сидить на дні
біля рибалки, який затонув.
І вона сидить і його оберігає.
Швиденько її підіймайте, –
каже нам Той, що греблі рве.
І от ми читаємо, як Русалка випливає.
Що таке знадливо?
Загравайчик, кокетно.
Русалки – затонулі дівчата,
які уособлюють собою стихію.
Вони можуть бути різними,
намагаються когось залоскотати,
затягнути у своє водне царство.
А от якою є наша Русалка,
ми зараз з вами з’ясуємо.
Отже, Русалка й Той, що греблі рве
зустрілися.
І він її питає: де ж ти була?
Що робила? Я тебе шукав.
А вона йому пояснює:
я плавала по морському дну,
проводила час, як вважала за необхідне.
А він каже, що мені це не подобається.
І тут вона хапає його за погляд
і каже: де ти барився, де ходив?
Не дарма паничі намагаються
якимось чином залицятися до неї.
Що таке мить?
Мить – це секунда – й немає.
Навіть менше.
Але "на цілу довгу
мить тобі я буду вірна".
Забуду, що ти десь мені з якоюсь
мельниківною зраджував,
тільки тому, що я тебе люблю.
Сто років минуло, пані Анастасіє,
а все так і залишилося.
І от вони говорять і тут
з’являється Водяник.
Перегортаймо сторінку
й читаємо, хто такий Водяник.
Баговиння – довгі тоненькі водорості.
Із койок – з молюсків.
Тобто він вбраний в мул.
Водяник розуміє, що це Русалка
й Той, що греблі рве.
Але Водянику не подобається
Той, що греблі рве. Чому?
Він каже: та знаю, знаю, не рідний він,
хоч і водяного роду.
А чому ж він нерідний? Що з ним не так?
Маріє, прочитайте нам, будь ласка.
У нього зрадлива вдача.
З одного боку, він весь нуртує,
грає, рве,
а коли настає літо й водичка висихає,
а лілея прихиляє голівку,
бо їй стає недобре.
Коли очерет гине, всій природі
не вистачає води, то де він тоді?
Не видно його тоді!
І де ж він, коли він так потрібний
своєму водяному царству? –
запитує Водяник.
А Той, що греблі рве виправдовується:
ну я тоді плаваю до океану,
в мене там більші місії й задачі.
Не можу вас тут підтримати.
Такий він молодий, бравий.
І от Водяник каже:
Русалко, ходімо зі мною, бо вже кудись
тим часом втік Той, що греблі рве.
А Русалка каже: та ні, я тут посиджу,
порозчісую рослинки своїм гребенем.
Виймає з волося гребінь і починає чесати.
А Водяник каже: ну тоді я дочекаюсь,
поки ти розчешеш, бо я люблю порядок.
Почекаю й поспостерігаю за тобою.
Водяник засинає, а Той, що греблі рве
звідкись з’являється
й починає казати: Русалко,
попливли кудись.
Він її забирає, вони починають пливти.
І от вона зачіпається за дуб.
«Ой, я зачепилася за дуб».
Вона відчуває, що щось не так.
І Водяник прокидається:
А Той, що греблі рве регоче -
Та я не боюся ніякої
метелиці!, нікого не боюся.
Сповняй коновки – наповнюй відра водою.
Коли прийде літо й буде сухо,
потрібна буде вода.
Ти не думай, що я прийду, краще
набирай одразу воду у відра.
А Русалка каже: я вільна,
я хочу пливти з ним,
а Водяник відповідає: в моїх володіннях
вода повинна знати береги.
Поки ти на моїй території, маєш
робити так, як кажу тобі я.
А не хочеш, то віддавай
свій венець перловий,
віддавай свою корону, Русалочко.
Той, що в скалі сидить – якась сила,
яка забирає і не віддає.
З ним познайомимося пізніше.
Але його бояться.
Його боіться сама природа.
Русалка каже, що буде слухатись,
а Водяник їй що відповідає?
То йди на дно!
Русалка спускається у воду,
усміхається й дивиться на батька.
А батько їй відповідає.
Він би потягнув твоє тіло по колючках.
Біле тіло понівечив і кинув би
самотню десь на безвідді.
О Боже!
Але ж він красивий –
який потужний аргумент.
Як не піти з Тим, що греблі рве,
якщо він гарний.
Прямо як я в 10 класі. Вибачте.
Пірнає знову під воду.
Тобто пролог почався з того,
що ми познайомилися з цим озером,
познайомились з цим прескрасним
середовищем, де відбуватиметься дія.
Ми познайомилися
з природніми персонажами.
Це був пролог?
Це був лише пролог!
Вау!
Це ми ще не перейшли навіть до дії.
Ще не познайомилися
з головними персонажами.
Познайомилися тільки з настроєм.
Що ця природа живе так,
як живемо ми, люди.
Це правда! При чому, не зважаючи на часи.
Той, що греблю рве дійсно
зводить з розуму Русалку.
А Водяний, як добрий батько,
намагається її захистити.
Він може їй пригрозити
Тим, що в скалі сидить,
але все одно природа бере своє,
бо він вродливий.
І є невидима сила, якої всі бояться,
бо вона руйнівна.
– Клас! Як цікаво ви розповідаєте!
Підсумуймо!
– Що вже закінчуємо?
Отже, "Лісова пісня" Лесі Українки
за жанром це драма-феєрія.
Є поєднання казкового, фантастичного
й драматичного тексту.
Ми дії читатимемо на наступних уроках.
Наше домашнє завдання:
Крок за кроком ми рухатимемося
цим текстом на наступних уроках.
Я чую дзвінок. Це означає,
що наш урок вже завершився.
Тож ідіть відпочивати сьогодні.
Наступного разу ми продовжимо.
Чесно кажучи, я сама попросила
урок української літератури,
тому що українську мову та літературу
я багато не вивчала.
Наприкінці школи в мене було
декілька місяців української,
бо це була Керчинська, Кримська школа,
де багато уваги не приділяли мові.
Я попросила літературу й не прогадала.
Мені так пощастило з пані Анастасією.
Вона виявилася… як краще сказати…
фанатичною вчителькою,
яка так добре ставиться
до свого предмету.
Просто фанатично!
Коли я зайшла, вона сказала:
прибрати телефон, сісти за парту
й сказати мені лише одне:
чому ви так мало викладаєте
українських книжок у вашій соцмережі?
І я зрозуміла, що не треба зараз
навіть розповідати, хто тут головний,
хто вчителька, а хто учениця, що я просто
дуже хотіла потрапити на урок.
Їй було однаково.
Бо треба пропагувати
українську літературу,
що я й зробила, щойно вийшовши з класу.